all right
asha where are you from originally
where'd you run
um where did i grow up silver lake help
ellen that way
and tell me about your family um my
father is peruvian my mom's korean i
was raised from my paternal side by my
grandmother
um a long line of alcoholic
i don't know so much about drug addicts
but big-time alcoholics is that why
your parents were out of the picture uh
no my parents were out of the picture
because
my mom wanted a green card not a
daughter she got stuck with a daughter
who she
quickly abandoned because she's to get
the [ __ ] beat out of her
so she left me with my dad who decided
that
um he would give me to his mom and
she raised me till i was 13 and then she
decided that she had done her job and
it's time for me to come back to live
with my dad so i lasted 12 months and i
moved out
and you moved out of what what age 14
14.
um and still how was life with your dad
um
hard you know he grew up very old school
um
the woman cooks cleans does everything
for
the man in this case um even though i
wasn't like
a wife i was still his daughter and his
form of correcting you
was very violent um
i he would you know punch
he he loved to punch me and uh
his favorite was like throwing chairs at
me so
um it wasn't exactly like the greatest
atmosphere
uh like i said i put up with it
full-time 12 months and i moved out
uh i was able to get a job with the city
i went painting murals in silver lake
for the summer
so earning my 4 15 an hour i was very
proud and said you know what
i don't need to put up with your [ __ ]
i'm out of here i never went home
i had a you know
crazy year being 14 and
ended up pregnant at 15 had my daughter
at 16 pregnant at 16 had my son at 17.
um by then i was very
very addicted to crack cocaine
um was fortunate i didn't use while i
was pregnant
um but soon after my son was born
i fell right back into it um
because that's how i survived i sold
crap i mean that's what i knew how to do
and
endless supply so it was easy for me to
just
fall into it long story short well my
son was about i don't know
a year and a half um he wanted me to
carry him
and i pushed him away because i need to
go take a hit
and uh that was my bottom i got sober
and was sober for 10 years raised my
kids
they are great amazing people
not like me but uh
you know [ __ ] happens life goes on right
so we moved to georgia so i could give
them the lifestyle that they deserved
and i met my current husband there
um he like i mentioned outside he was
in the military for eight years four of
which i was with him
we went through one deployment together
to afghanistan
and uh he came back a very different
person
and i turned back into
what i guess i tried to get away from
and uh
unfortunately i ended up in jail for
aggravated assault
met the wrong girl and tried heroin
brought it home and just
it was uh an endless
insatiable like stomach to feed
you know i didn't know what kind of
addicts my husband was i knew what kind
of addict i was
and if it's in my face i can't say no i
have to do it
so uh he'd make sure that there was
just enough for me to [ __ ] up that day
so i couldn't [ __ ] at him
woke up sick one day a couple years
later we lost everything
so after 20 years of not selling dope i
went right back to selling it
and i kept us off the streets for about
a year we stayed in hotels
and uh i caught charges eventually
ended up finding a rehab for couples
which is really unheard of
we lasted a week we got kicked out
because of our anger issues
and the idea was since he was received a
pension we'd
go to mexico and live comfortably if
anything and still be able to get high
of course
but um when we got here we needed about
two weeks till he got his paycheck for
us to cross into mexico
while we were here um our ids and his
bank card got stolen
so we got sucked into downtown
um it's it's been very wild
you know um
good example i i recently had to like um
leave the downtown area and go to
macarthur because
some of the black sets some of the males
had
pretty much kept their eye on me um
because i'm loyal to my husband and i
know how to make money
by hustling selling whatever not myself
so they took
um how do i put this
basically they had a meeting
so to speak and said these are the mails
from these sets that they were
interested in making me
a new boss or a boss [ __ ]
i guess it's what it's called and so i
had a choice
i could become what they wanted
and my husband could come along for the
ride and not be hurt
or they would just take me
and put me in a tent and do what they
wanted and my husband would get [ __ ]
off
so we went to macarthur where there's
my race and looked for i guess sanctuary
there
it's worked out so far but it's
it's never a dull moment ever
there's a there's so many compromises
um that you have to make out here
where are you living now um across the
street from
yoshinoya uh on colorado
um at mccarthy park yeah in macarthur
park
did attend yeah in a tent so with your
with your husband yes with my husband
that part's not so bad believe it or not
um so everything that goes on around it
that's kind of bad although i do miss
running water so how does macarthur park
compare to skid row
it's the same but it's very different i
mean it's the same
uh you know you have that is run down
and
is you know downtown isn't what it used
to be though
uh they had all these facelifts and and
but skid row still skid row and it's
still you know
downtown has improved but skid row is
still it's still spinning
it is and um it probably
always will be until they decide to move
the entire homeless population to a
whole other area
which you know with everything that's
happening right now could happen
um
i think part of it is you know you you
come up seeing
something and it's all you know so why
fix it if it's not broken
because nobody realizes just how broken
we all are out here
we don't or maybe we do and we choose
not to see it
so we get high or we go
do whatever mission
just to take our mind off of what's
really going on
and it gets old but it's you know
today's adventure we're all a bunch of
big kids out here man
i mean i know i am i i like step back
and see some of the things that
like we do and try to look at it from an
outsider's point of view and it's like
man
i'm 14 again i'm going you know with my
on this little convoy to find a
place to go get high where the cops
won't find us where
this used to be pot now it's it's it's
adults living with no responsibility
right and there's such an allure to that
but believe it or not
there's so many more rules out here i
mean
it's the real world doesn't have [ __ ] on
us out here
because you have to make sure that you
don't say the wrong thing
or look the wrong way it's a different
set of rules very different but
that don't make sense all the time it's
kind of like math laws
it just always has been it changes block
by block true
but it's just the way it's always been
so it always will be
you know there's again why fix it and it
allows those that are strong to survive
and those that aren't
to not do you prefer this lifestyle to
one where you
have a job and you pay bills and you
have responsibilities i don't know that
i prefer it i'm
comfortable and it's familiar to me it's
what i grew up knowing
um
growing up with my grandmother i mean
you know as an adult you look back at
your childhood and whatnot and
you know in a way it's like how can i
not be what i am today which is
how can i not hustle i remember my
grandmother showing
um you know money into my
great-grandfather's suit
to go to peru back home to peru
you know [ __ ] like that and you think
that you're like well wait a minute
that's not very legal weren't they
supposed to report that
so it's just sometimes things that we go
through
lead us to a point in life that we have
no idea what
or where we're going um we're just i'm
just trying to
keep my head above water it gets hard
it gets old but it's what i do
you feel like you're following in
someone's footsteps
not really um i'm
i mean as far as like the the normal
or not normal but the average stereotype
of a
female out here not even really that but
you don't see any
behaviors in your parents that you're
kind of
i mean i have i'm kind of amoral like
things that should not be
okay with me are you know uh it's so
like i don't really look down on maybe
not paying your taxes on time
things like that you know things like
that are kind of trivial but it's just
it's relative it's just a different
level i guess than out here it's like
it's uh
you know uh it's okay to i guess
maybe skirt on paying the bill at the
store so we go and
some of us will shoplift or what have
you and we know it's wrong i know it's
wrong
but i'll take the merchandise if i need
it
you know um it's whatever i have to do
to survive so you
is the cutting on your left arm from
long ago or from recent no i'm still a
cutter you're still cutting
yeah um i've i've done quite well
i'd say in the last year i i've only cut
maybe once or twice and it wasn't very
deep
but uh started when i was 14 and just
like any other addiction
uh i had it had to get worse more
stitches deeper
just to fix the same have you ever
thought you were truly suicidal or is it
just like a call for attention
um no i i mean i've woken up on life
support before
so or that sounds so dramatic you know a
ventilator
what have you so that's also one of the
reasons why we uh
we being me and my kids moved to georgia
about 14 years ago
um i'd had a really bad episode never
really dealt with my depression
and uh went on a i guess
i don't know i guess from what i was
told i started on a friday and woke up
on a monday
with a machine breathing for me and uh
i'd been really really just upset and
depressed
overall about life um
my great aunt uh she was the eldest
of our elders on my dad's side uh
had basically turned her back on me and
she's the only person i had had who
loved me unconditionally
unfortunately she's mentally ill and it
was my
obligation to have her committed for the
first time in her life
so she stopped interacting with me at
night i couldn't take it
so um apparently i od'd
on a whole bunch of crap pills and booze
and whatnot
but as far as the cutting's concerned um
you know it's in designs because i
didn't want my kids growing up knowing
that their mom was not okay
so i could lie to him and tell him oh
it's just a tattoo without ink
because you know kids are supposed to be
kids they're not supposed to worry that
their mom's
not all right today and
i mean it worked until it didn't
and when it didn't it was really really
bad
i got drunk
and ended up getting like over 100
stitches that night
unfortunately in the process of cutting
i woke up my kids
and they saw me being pretty much
carried out to my car you know big old
bloody mess and they'd never seen that
they didn't know
so i think that was a lot worse than
maybe as they were getting older sitting
them down being like hey
this is what's really going on but
i didn't i didn't i don't know i had an
idea
of what a good parent was supposed to be
because i learned everything to not do
from my parents
and sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't
um any other questions no that's good
asha thank you so much for talking with
me and no problem good luck and
hope you and your husband figure this
out oh we will we've been here over here
you